Jeremy Renner's Clint Barton has
remained on the sidelines of the MCU,
but the Disney+ streaming service is
about to change that with "Hawkeye."
We've set our sights on everything you'll
want to know about the superhero series.
Despite many Marvel's other Disney+ series getting
shuffled around due to the COVID-19 pandemic,
it seems as though "Hawkeye" may always
have been destined for a holiday release.
The six-episode season will begin its run the day
before Thanksgiving, with the first two episodes
dropping on November 24, 2021. Subsequent episodes
will release weekly, with the finale releasing on
December 22. That's perfect timing for the
holiday-themed series, which seems to follow
Clint Barton as he fights to get home with his
family in time to celebrate Christmas together.
"Should we be worried?"
"I'll be home for Christmas, I promise."
Two-time Oscar nominee Jeremy Renner has
long been one of the more underutilized
members of the original Avengers, but that
will all change with "Hawkeye." His solo
series will mark the first time the character
has ever had a central role in an MCU story.
Clint Barton's only appearances outside
the "Avengers" movies thus far consist of
a brief cameo in "Thor" and a supporting role in
"Captain America: Civil War." Renner didn't even
appear in "Avengers: Infinity War," his absence
explained in a single line from Natasha Romanoff.
"Where's Clint?"
"After the whole Accord situation,
he and Scott took a deal. It was too tough
on their families. They're on house arrest."
While Hawkeye did have a meatier role to play
in "Avengers: Endgame," it'll be nice to see
him finally take center stage. However, even
in his own eponymous series, he won't be alone.
Along with the announcement that Renner would be
picking up Clint Barton's bow and arrows again
came the exciting news that "Hawkeye" would
see him passing the torch to Kate Bishop.
As fans of the "Hawkeye" comics are
well aware, Kate is Barton's protege
who takes up the Hawkeye mantle herself. She is
eventually given Barton's bow to use as her own.
"What I get to do ultimately in
the show is shepherd an amazing
character to be, ultimately,
probably a better version of me."
"Hawkeye" will draw inspiration from the
recent comics run from writer Matt Fraction
and artist David Aja, in which Bishop is
Barton's occasional partner in fighting crime.
The character in the comics is young,
strong-willed, and doesn't shy away from danger.
In Marvel Studios' "Hawkeye," Kate Bishop will
be played by Hailee Steinfeld. The actress was
confirmed in the role in late 2020 after being
rumored for the role of Kate for more than a year.
Speaking to Collider about her
involvement, Steinfeld said,
"I'm just so honored to be a part of the MCU
... It's been a wonderful experience, developing
this character and taking elements of her from
the comics and what we know with her history."
"Hawkeye" is Steinfeld's first live-action
superhero role. However, she's no stranger
to the genre or to Marvel's expansive roster
of characters, having voiced Spider-Gwen in
the Oscar-winning animated film "Spider-Man: Into
the Spider-Verse." Additionally, Steinfeld also
already has her own Oscar nomination under her
belt for her role in the Coen Brothers' 2010
remake of "True Grit." In the film, which was
also her feature film debut, she starred as the
determined Mattie Ross alongside Matt Damon, Jeff
Bridges, and eventual MCU villain Josh Brolin.
Considering Steinfeld's impressive resume,
she seems more than capable of going toe to
toe — or perhaps we should say, bow to
bow — with Jeremy Renner in "Hawkeye."
And who knows, depending on what happens
in "Hawkeye," it's possible Kate Bishop
could go on to play an even bigger part
in the MCU than Clint Barton ever did.
Jeremy Renner isn't the only Marvel
actor set to return in "Hawkeye."
Ben Sakamoto, Ava Russo, and Cade Woodward will
be reprising their roles as Barton's children
Cooper, Lila, and Nathaniel Barton, who were
last seen at the end of "Avengers: Endgame."
While Clint Barton was the opposite of
a family man in Matt Fraction's comics,
the Barton family has been a huge part
of Hawkeye's characterization in the MCU.
His grief over their loss in "the Blip"
functioned as his motivation for becoming the
assassin Ronin at the beginning of "Avengers:
Endgame." Later, the possibility of getting
them back served as Barton's incentive to
rejoin the Avengers on their time heist.
Emmy nominee Linda Cardellini will also
be reprising her role from the MCU films
as Clint's wife Laura. Cardellini has most
recently been co-starring with Christina
Applegate in the Netflix series "Dead to Me,"
which has a third and final season forthcoming.
Although we don't yet know how big a role Laura
Barton will play in "Hawkeye," trailers have
confirmed that the Bartons' marriage still
appears to be in decent shape — assuming,
of course, that Clint can make
it home in time for Christmas.
Jeremy Renner and Hailee Steinfeld may be
sharing top billing as the lead characters
of "Hawkeye," but they're far from the
only serious acting talent in the series.
Oscar-nominee and "The Conjuring" series co-star
Vera Farmiga has been cast as Kate Bishop's
mother Eleanor, while Tony Dalton is slated to
play Jack Duquesne, also known as Swordsman,
one of Clint Barton's mentors. Duqusne has had
both heroic and villainous arcs in the comics,
so it will be interesting to see in
what direction the series takes him.
"Hawkeye" will also serve as the live-action debut
of Maya Lopez, who adopts the superhero name Echo.
In the comics, Maya is a deaf Native American
woman who has the power to perfectly mimic human
movements, giving her the ability to quickly adapt
to a wide variety of skills and combat styles.
She'll be played by deaf actor Alaqua Cox,
who is from the Menominee and Mohican nations.
"Hawkeye" will serve as Cox's screen debut,
but Marvel Studios seems to already have a
lot of faith in her; the studio is already moving
ahead with development on Echo's own solo series.
Maya's father William will be played by veteran
actor Zahn McClarnon, who you may recognize from
"Westworld" and "Longmire." The Lopez family
has a deep history in the world of the comics,
with Echo's storylines closely intertwining with
characters such as Daredevil and Moon Knight.
It remains to be seen if she and William
will play a significant role in "Hawkeye,"
or if their appearances will serve as more
of a set up to Echo's eventual spin-off.
On the villain side of things, Florence Pugh will
also be appearing in "Hawkeye" as Yelena Belova,
sister of Clint's dearly departed bestie,
Natasha Romanoff. The Oscar-nominated actor
recently had a huge MCU breakout moment
in "Black Widow," in which the two women
teamed up to take down the man responsible
for their abusive training in the Red Room.
However, while Yelena largely acted as a
hero in the film, things take a turn in
"Black Widow"'s post-credit scene. The scene
finds Yelena mourning Natasha's death at her
sister's gravesite when she's approached
by Contessa Valentina Allegra de Fontaine,
who was introduced in "The Falcon and the Winter
Soldier" as one of the newer behind-the-scenes
power players of the MCU. The Contessa tells
Yelena that she has a new target for her,
paving the way for her appearance in "Hawkeye."
"Maybe you'd like a shot at the man
responsible for your sister's death."
But Yelena won't be the only character blocking
Clint's path to a festive family Christmas.
Irish actor Fra Fee has been cast as a
villainous character referred to in the show
as Kazi. In a Tweet around the time of his
casting announcement, Fee indicated that Kazi
will be a live-action take on Kazimierz
Kazimierczak, also known as The Clown.
And of course, then there's the Tracksuit
Draculas. The primary antagonists in Matt
Fraction's "Hawkeye" comics are members of the
Russian mafia, whom Clint dubs the "Tracksuit
Draculas," due to their heavy accents and their
affinity for wearing velour tracksuits. These
Russian mobsters have an extremely limited English
vocabulary, relying heavily on the words "bro" and
"seriously" to convey the bulk of their meaning.
They drive much of the small-scale conflict of
Fraction's comics, which tend to center on
the tenants of Barton's apartment building.
Trailers have confirmed that the Tracksuit
Draculas will be teaming up to take down
Clint Barton. The trailer also gives us
a glimpse of boxer-turned-actor Aleks
Paunovic playing a character who seems to be Ivan
Banionis, the leader of the Tracksuit Draculas.
Considering the Tracksuit Draculas storyline
from the comics is very tied up with Barton's
characterization as a single, childless guy
living in New York City, there will no doubt be
some changes to how the villains are portrayed
in the Disney+ series. But, seriously bro,
no matter how they wind up on the wrong side of
Clint's trick arrows, we're happy to see them.
Between taking on the many villains of New York
City and the vengeance-seeking sister of one of
his closest friends, one thing is certain: Clint
will have his hands full this holiday season.
Fraction's "Hawkeye" comics feature a
wide assortment of interesting characters,
any one of whom would make a welcome addition
to the MCU. Possible allies for Clint and Kate
include Clint's brother, Barney Barton;
Clint's friend and neighbor, Grills;
or Penny, the ex-wife of one of the Tracksuit
Draculas. Bobbi Morse, also known as Mockingbird,
and Jessica Drew, also known as Spider-Woman,
also appear in the Hawkeye comics. However,
since the MCU version of Clint is happily married,
their roles as Clint's ex-wife and current
girlfriend, respectively, would likely have to
be rewritten for the show if they were to appear.
The character of Bobbi Morse has already appeared
on the TV show "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.," where
she was portrayed by Adrianne Palicki. However,
FandomWire reports that Palicki won't be reprising
her role for "Hawkeye," and that the character
will be recast. Similarly, speculation is swirling
among MCU fans that the character "Game of
Thrones" star Emilia Clarke will be playing
in the upcoming "Secret Invasion" series is in
fact Jessica Drew. If that turns out to be true,
could the character make her first appearance
in "Hawkeye"? Who knows, but it wouldn't be
the first time Marvel has thrown a surprise
character introduction into one of their shows.
Speaking of MCU tie-ins, in one issue of
Fraction's "Hawkeye," Clint briefly teams up
with Wolverine and Spider-Man to battle members
of Advanced Idea Mechanics. Otherwise known as
A.I.M., the group is an organization of evil
scientists that serve as one of the various
villainous groups in the Marvel Universe. However,
it's only a minor subplot, and the "Hawkeye"
series could easily nod to it while swapping out
most of the details. Not only could "Hawkeye"
substitute some different villains since A.I.M.
was last seen in "Iron Man 3," but the series
could also pull in a totally different pair of
Avengers. Possibly some avengers with closer ties
to Clint than Spider-Man or Wolverine, especially
since the latter still hasn't made his MCU debut.
Perhaps instead, Clint might team up with
Wanda Maximoff, with whom he already has
somewhat of a mentoring relationship.
Other candidates could include Clint's
former S.H.I.E.L.D. colleagues like Nick Fury
and Maria Hill, or Sam Wilson and Bucky Barnes.
Even someone like Scott Lang could make sense,
especially if his daughter Cassie shows up.
In the Matt Fraction comics, Kate Bishop is
already a former member of the superhero team
Young Avengers. However, considering the
Young Avengers don't yet exist in the MCU,
it may make more sense for "Hawkeye" to be the
property that sets up their eventual introduction.
Kate isn't the first potential Young Avenger to
enter the MCU. The first was Ant-Man's daughter,
Cassie Lang, who aged into a teenager
during the time jump in "Avengers: Endgame."
In the comics, Cassie follows in her father's
footsteps by using Pym particles to become the
size-altering superhero Stature, and is
close friends with Kate Bishop's Hawkeye.
Cassie has since been followed by Billy and
Tommy, the twin sons of Wanda Maximoff and Vision.
While the brothers disappeared along with
the rest of Wanda's conjured world at the
end of "WandaVision," they reappeared as spectral
voices during the post-credit scene in the finale.
"Mom, help please"
In the comics, Billy and Tommy grow up to
be the Young Avengers Wiccan and Speed.
In "The Falcon and the Winter Soldier," we briefly
met Elijah Bradley, grandson of Isaiah Bradley,
the Black Captain America. In the comics, Elijah
takes up the mantle of the Young Avenger known as
Patriot. And "Loki" introduced us
to the character of Young Loki,
a variant form of the character who is also
part of the Young Avengers team in the comics.
With nearly the entire Young Avengers
roster already established in the MCU,
we wouldn't be surprised if "Hawkeye" finally
lays the groundwork for the team to come together.
Arguably one of the best parts of
Fraction's "Hawkeye" run is Clint's dog,
Lucky. The two are introduced when Clint saves
the pooch from one of the Tracksuit Draculas,
and then adopts him. While his tag
reads "Arrow," Clint renames him Lucky.
Clint's canine companion will be played
by a golden retriever named Jolt, and the
character's inclusion in the series opens up a
wide range of story possibilities. In the comics,
he even partakes in a few adventures of his
own. He accompanies Kate when she moves to L.A.,
helps Clint track down Tracksuit
Draculas, and even gets shot at
one point. If the series goes this route,
don't worry — Lucky recovers just fine.
Serving as writer and executive producer
for "Hawkeye" is Jonathan Igla. While Igla
has produced several other shows, including the
short-lived but critically beloved series "Pitch,"
he's best known for his work on AMC's juggernaut
series "Mad Men," where he served as a writer
and executive story editor. Although Igla's resume
doesn't boast much experience with the high-octane
action the MCU is known for, his style may be
perfect for the more character-driven "Hawkeye."
After all, "Mad Men" was widely celebrated for
its outstanding characters, snappy dialogue,
and strong storytelling, three elements that
also stood out in Matt Fraction's "Hawkeye" run.
Fraction's "Hawkeye" storylines tended
to revolve around the question of what
a superhero does when he's not being a superhero.
While Fraction's run did have its fair share of
bad guys and sinister plots, each issue tended
to focus less on Clint Barton's extraordinary
abilities and more on his regular day-to-day life.
Of course, we also expect plenty of MCU superhero
action from "Hawkeye." But if the series
is using Fraction's comics as a roadmap,
we can expect for it to be focused on small-scale
personal conflicts and character relationships
far more than hugely powerful supervillains,
making Igla the perfect choice to helm the series.
After being blissfully absent for all of
"Avengers: Infinity War," Clint Barton
had a rough time during "Avengers: Endgame." The
film opened with Barton's wife and three children
turning to dust before his eyes, following the
Avengers' failure to stop Thanos in "Infinity
War." The next time we saw him after the film's
five-year time jump, he had left the superhero
mantle of Hawkeye behind, and had become the
ruthless vigilante known as Ronin. His best friend
Natasha eventually tracks him down in Japan after
he has just murdered a street full of Yakuza,
offering him hope with their plan for the
time heist. But while Clint is ultimately
able to get his family back by the end of the
movie, it's at the cost of Natasha's life.
With the "Hawkeye" series confirmed to
take place after the events of "Endgame,"
that leaves a lot for Clint to be reckoning
with the next time we see him. Not only will he
likely still be mourning the loss of Natasha,
whose death he tried and failed to prevent,
but he'll also have to face the horrible things
he did as Ronin. That's not even to mention that
he'll have super-spy Yelena after him, seeking
retribution for Natasha's death. Additionally,
we can probably expect to see how the Barton
family is coping with the aftermath of "the
Blip," since coming back after five years
as dust is sure to be a sizeable adjustment.
Trailers for "Hawkeye" see the superhero
taking his kids on a fun trip to New York City,
but of course, those plans quickly go sideways.
The trailers indicate that the main plot of
"Hawkeye" will revolve around Clint getting
stuck in New York City away from his family
before Christmas, battling bad guys that
are somehow tied to his days as Ronin.
Complicating matters is that it appears the
entire New York underworld is after Clint,
while he lacks the superhuman strength and
resilience of his extraordinary teammates.
Of course, Hawkeye's lack of superpowers
has always been a running gag in the MCU.
"The city is flying, we're
fighting an army of robots,
and I have a bow and arrow.
None of this makes sense."
But for Clint, being a hero has always
been more about a mindset than superpowers,
and it seems that theme will
carry over to his solo series.
It seems likely that despite the
Tracksuit Draculas and many other
villains threatening Clint, the main focus
of the "Hawkeye" series will be on Clint
training Kate to eventually take over for
him. Teaching Kate that she doesn't need
powers in order to accomplish great things
would be in line with Fraction's comics,
which are much more interested in Clint's
everyday attitude than in his enhanced skillset.
"You want to be a superhero?
You put your life in danger."
Keeping with the theme of focusing
on Hawkeye's most human qualities,
Renner has confirmed that Barton's hearing loss
will play a factor in "Hawkeye," as it did in
Fraction's comics. Considering we know that Echo
will be appearing in the series, we wouldn't be
surprised if hearing loss and deafness turn
out to be a significant part of "Hawkeye."
Will Clint and Kate be able to take on the
Tracksuit Draculas and other various Marvel
baddies in time for Clint to make it home
for Christmas on the farm with his family?
And will Clint finally retire for good
and pass the mantle to his young protege?
We'll find out when the first two episodes of
"Hawkeye" shoot onto Disney+ on November 24, 2021.
"It's gonna be the best Christmas ever."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.